25 ans après le succès mondial du livre
le palanquin des larmes son héroïne Cho
chingli revient sur le devant de la
scène pour nous raconter la suite de sa
vie souvent douloureuse jeune vievv mol
et Claude Barnier ont suivi au fin fond
d'une vallée de la Chine du Sud celle
qui se retrouve enfin dans la main de
Bouddha c'est le titre de son nouveau
livre si elle n'avait été mariée de
force à 13 ans et séparée de son piano
chingli serait devenue une grande
concertiste chinoise de shangï puis de
Paris elle demeure pourtant une servante
de
chopain la musique a pas de fontier pour
moi c'est la musique c'est l'amour plein
d'amour dans le C qui
son mais dès qu'elle le peut l'héroïne
du palenquin des larmes retrouve avec
ferveur les Litan du temple de gauming
enfou dans la vallée de tiille en Chine
du Sud c'est là que shoshinli a
rencontré Boudha et qu'il lui a donné sa
paix c'était en
1962 avant les atrocités de la
Révolution culturelle avant que les
gardes de rouges ne détruisent les dieux
n'assassinent les Bones n'installent des
ports dans les lieux de
prière des années plus tard elle qui a
sacrifié sa vie à travailler pour sa
famille restere en Chine décide de
financer la reconstruction de gauming
elle est vite supplantée par les paysans
qui enfin libres peuvent exprimer leur
attachement au bouddhisme les paysans et
puis les habitants de toute sa région
donne même une petite barque de tout ce
qu'ils ont une
petite bijoux petits chos tout ce qu'ils
ont le rassemblé pour faire un
cing dans ce livre qu'elle vient
d'écrire avec son ami Isabelle Garnier
choshinli poursuit son récit commencé
avec le palenquin des larmes celle qui a
connu la misère puis la servitude dans
le mariage a pu devenir à force de
travailler de courage une entrepreneuse
libre à Paris
il a un grand changement dans le le
statut de la femme chinoise qu'elle a
vécu c'est-à-dire elle elle a été mariée
à 13 ans elle était la femme cinoise
soumise et elle est devenue la femme
chinoise chef de famille maintenant
complètement c'est extraordinaire elle
elle symbolise vraiment une évolution
une histoire oui ce récit dans la main
de Bouddha est aussi un surprenant
témoignage sur cette Chine en pleine
expansion à l'image de shanghï qui pour
ne pas perdre la tête face à la
modernité et l'argent replonge avec
force dans le bouddhisme
ancestral